Qui suis-je vraiment ... un YouTubeur faisant ça par passion ?
Ou un escroc faisant ça uniquement pour l'argent et n'étant pas du tout pareil dans la vraie vie que dans ses vidéos...
On va très vite le savoir !
Parce-qu'aujourd'hui
On fait un test scientifique!!
Eh ouais mon pote...
J'ai bien dit le mot "scientifique" sur cette chaîne YouTube... !
Qui pensait que ça arriverait un jour ?! HEIN?!
Nos lecteurs disent que le test de seis-s-ei-sixteen personnalities.... (Bafouillage)
C'est insupportable, je suis insupportable...
Bon on reprend notre sérieux aujourd'hui on est sur 16 personnalités !
D'habitude on fait des quiz qui sont un peu what the fuck... un peu du gros bullshit, on va pas se mentir...
MAIS LÀ! C'est un quizz très...très approfondi
On va répondre à une série de questions hyper précises
Et à la fin on va nous dire... quelle est ma personnalité
Apparemment le test est si exact qu'il fait un peu peur...
Voilà, .... "passez le test"
Eh ça me fout la pression parce que je sais que c'est pas une connerie, je sais que c'est.. un peu scientifique là
Vous avez des difficultés à vous présenter à d'autres personnes
...
Franchement, ouais...
C'est jamais évident, je trouve, de se présenter à des inconnus...
Attends j'essaie... :
Salut !...
Moi c'est Lucas et je fais euuuh... des vidéos sur Internet
Bah nan du coup j'ai pas du mal, c'est très court (rires)
Non franchement.. non on va dire,
Je suis d'accord, j'aime pas... j'aime pas trop me présenter à d'autres personnes.
Vous êtes souvent si perdu dans vos pensées que vous ignorez ou oubliez votre entourage.
C'est horrible...c'est méga vrai mec
Des fois je fais des phases on dirait limite que je suis en hypnose, tu sais
Je fais la statue pendant 30 secondes, j'entends ta voix étouffée là
(voix en arrière fond) Mais je m'en bats les c*uilles mon gars
parce que je suis tellement bien dans mes pensées *J'te quitte* que du co-QUOI ?
Vous essayez de répondre dès que possible à vos e-mails et ne supportez pas d'avoir une boîte de messagerie mal organisée
M'en bats les c*uilles frère *rires*
Attends regarde... regarde si elle est pas mal organisée
14 253 Mails non lus
Bats les c*uilles frère !
Vous avez des facilités à rester serein(e) et concentré(e), même lorsque certaines situations donnent lieu à une certaine pression
*Réfléchi*
Ah ouai ça, ça va j'ai pas d'argumentation à faire c'est vrai tu me fais confiance *rires*
Habituellement, vous ne lancez pas les conversations
C'est vrai aussi étonnamment que ça puisse paraître je lance rarement les conversations
Vous vous sentez supérieur(e) aux autres
Oh ! C'est une question qui blesse ça
Comme tout le monde ça dépend de qui est en face.
Et ça dépend aussi du sujet, tu peux pas être supérieur tout court à quelqu'un
Donc neutre, là j'ai envie de répondre "neutre" quoi bah euh ... pff
Peut-être un peu... Je sais pas. Je sais pas du tout mec!
Il y a pas la réponse "ça dépend de qui est en face et de quel sujet on parle"?
Non.
Bon allez vas-y je vais mettre 1 pour combler
Vous êtes généralement très motivé plein d'énergie.
Là là là Là, vous croyez tous que je vais mettre oui à fond, bah franchement, ça dépend
Ça dépend totalement. Quand je suis dans ma vidéo, ouais, je suis très motivé, plein d'énergie, mais avant des fois je suis vraiment en mode zombie hein.
Bon vas-y on va dire d'accord. On va pas se mentir ok?
Oh ça attends, alors ça
"Gagner un débat vous importe moins que d'avoir la certitude que personne n'est contrarié."
Pas d'accord mais level max mon gars !
*rires*
Je suis la pire des p**** mon gars quand je fais un débat.
J'ai absolument besoin que l'issue du débat ce soit : soit j'ai tort, soit j'ai raison.
Mais ça ne peut pas se terminer par personne n'est contrarié, dès que j'ai un débat
avec des proches je vous jure ça par sûr en embrouille pendant 10 minutes. Et à la fin on sait qui a raison et qui avait tort.
Et souvent j'ai... raison.
Parce que je me crois supérieur aux autres. Pfff
"Au travail et au domicile, votre environnement de vie est assez ordonné."
Ouais un peu d'accord allez un peu d'accord.
C'est pas non plus le gros rangement mais bon...
"Cela ne vous dérange pas d'être le centre de l'attention." Euh...
Pas d'accord du tout mec. J'aime pas du tout quand je suis avec des gens
et ça se met à parler de moi. J'aime pas du tout.
Par contre être au centre de l'attention du genre tu fais des, des blagues, de la merde
ou t'es chaud au bowling ou je sais pas quoi
Ça je m'en fous un peu mais, mais dès que ça parle
de moi autour de moi je supporte pas. "Vos itinéraires de voyage sont généralement
planifiés à l'avance." Carrément.
"Votre humeur peut changer très rapidement." Totalement vrai. *rires*
Oh ça on enchaîne on enchaîne.
"Au cours d'une discussion, la vérité doit passer avant la susceptibilité de chacun."
Totalement d'accord *rires*
En fait, peut-être parce que moi je me vexe rarement.
Et au contraire, j'aime bien quand, justement, quand j'ai tord.
Et quand j'apprends des choses, bah du coup euh...
Bah du coup je considère que tout le monde doit être comme ça. Et ça c'est un vilain défaut.
Je me mets nu là, devant vous. Je me mets à poil.
"Votre style de travail s'approche plus de pics d'énergie aléatoires que d'une approche méthodique et organisée."
Oh c'est un peu des deux!
C'est un peu des deux, hein. Le pic d'énergie là on y est.
Là on est tout en haut de la courbe.
Mais il y a quand même une petite approche méthodique et organisée dans le sens
Tel jour j'vais tourner deux trucs... Ensuite là j'ai ça, ensuite truc.
Bon, ouais j'avoue ok, c'est plus des pics. *rires*
Je m'organise pas très bien.
"Un livre ou un jeu vidéo de qualité sont souvent mieux qu'une soirée mondaine."
C'est horrib'... C'est vrai, c'est vrai. "Etre capable de développer un plan
et de s'y tenir est la partie la plus importante de chaque projet."
C'est vrai mais je le respecte pas. Mais je suis d'accord. Mais je le respecte pas...
"Vous êtes souvent perdu dans vos pensées lorsque vous marchez dans la nature."
Mais euh... 100% des gens!
100% des gens mec. Quand tu marches d'un point A à un point B tu te fais royalement chier.
Tu penses à plein de trucs, tu gagnes du temps en fait.
C'est des trucs au quels t'auras pas à penser quand justement tu auras moyen de t'occuper.
Et pas te faire chier comme t'es censé te faire chier quand tu marches.
Là vous venez tous de quitter la vidéo et c'est normal hein
Personne n'a compris *rires*
"En tant que parent vous préféreriez voir votre enfant devenir gentil plutôt qu'intelligent."
Ça c'est compliqué je trouve. Parce que les gens trop gentils
ils se laissent beaucoup marcher dessus en fait.
Et j'ai pas envie que mon enfant se laisse marcher dessus.
Il faut être gentil mais il y a des situations ou tu peux ne pas être gentil et...
Même moi j'ai tendance à être trop gentil.
Enfin plus trop maintenant ... j'ai tué quelqu'un hier.
Mais sinon ouais. Je préfère quand même qu'il soit gentil.
Ouais je suis un peu d'accord ok.
"Vous ne laissez pas les autres influencer vos actions."
C'est faux . C'est faux de ouf!
Au contraire pendant longtemps j'ai beaucoup trop laissé les autres influencer mes actions mais parce que
mais je trouve pas que ça soit une mauvaise chose au contraire
je trouve que ça veut dire que tu apportes de la confiance à des gens et
quand ils te font une remarque ou un truc bah euh
ils le disent pas pour rien tu le prends vraiment en compte
et souvent du coup ça influence sur mes actions c'est vrai
Vos rêves ont tendance à se concentrer sur le monde réel et ses événements.
Mec je fais jamais de rêve
C'est hyper triste
*musique triste* Je suis un grand rêveur mais je fais jamais de rêve
mais je fais des petites punchlines de poésie
ouais ouais vas-y un peu d'accord on va dire
Vous êtes plus du genre à improviser naturellement qu'à tout planifier minutieusement.
ouais
c'est vrai
Vous appréciez d'aller à des soirées déguisées ou de participer à des jeux de rôle.
ouais
c'est vrai
Vos émotions vous contrôlent plus que vous ne les contrôlez.
ouais
c'est vrai
ça vous plait d'avoir cette réponse en boucle
*rires*
moi je suis en vacances du coup
j'ai plus besoin de parler
j'ai mon quizz tranquille et je mets cette réponse à chaque fois après avoir lu la question
Si vos amis sont vraiment tristes à propos d'une situation, vous êtes plus susceptibles de leur offrir un soutien émotionnel que de leur suggérer des solutions au problème.
Ah non ça je suis horrible
En fait quand la situation je la trouve aberrante
j'arrive pas à être "oh mais ça va aller"
je suis plus "MAIS FERME LA!!! POURQUOI TU CHIALES!!!"
"FAIS CA ET CA AUSSI"
En travail d'équipe, il est plus important d'avoir raison que d'être coopératif.
j'pense que je vais dire oui
il est plus important d'avoir raison que d'être coopératif parce qu'en fait
quand j'étais plus jeune j'ai grandi avec ma mère et ma mère elle était vraiment
quand il y a un débat il fallait qu'elle ait raison
tout le temps il fallait qu'elle ait raison
et c'est pour ça que moi même aujourd'hui, quand il y a un débat il faut un mec qui ait tort ou qui ait raison
mais par contre il y a aucun problème avec le fait que je peux avoir tort
alors que ma mère elle voulait jamais avoir tort
donc des fois ça devenait horrible
c'est tu lui montrais par A+B qu'elle avait tort
et non elle ne voulait pas l'admettre quoi c'est horrible
les gens comme ça qui ont une p**** de coquille fermée
tu as envie de prendre un p***** couteau et de les ouvrir comme des huîtres et de les
PLANTER!!!
pardon
j'ai jamais planté ma mère attention
après la c'est en travail d'équipe, en travail d'équipe comment je fais
nan j'avoue, nan, Overwatch par exemple, typiquement quand un truc va pas
je vais dire "c'est parce qu'il y a ça ça ça" et je vais pas êtr-...bah si
Je suis coopératif, je prends un heal quand il manque un heal
P'tain, je vois partout overwatch
faut que j’arrête ... faut ... que je sorte ce
Dumbledore, viens retire moi euh, de mes souvenir, Overwatch, s'il-te-plaît.
"Vous pensez que les opinions de tous doivent être respectées, indépendamment du fait qu'elles soient justifiées ou non par des faits"
J'suis d'accord.
Peu importent les opinions
Enfin bon, sauf les opinion très extrêmes euh ...
Euh par exemple ... << ni*** les juifs on va les brûler >>
Euh ça ... Euuuuh
J-j-j j'ai pas forcément envie de respecter cette opinion
hormis les trucs extrêmes oui, je pense que toutes les opinions doivent être respectées elle sont justifiées par un vécu en fait.
"votre énergie est multipliée si vous avez passé du temps avec un groupe."
Totalement vrai, mais tout le monde, c'est normal
"Vous vous souciez trop de ce que pensent les gens"
A HAAA ... question intéressante pour un YouTubeur
Un peu, ouais, un peu
En fait je relie ça à la vérité
Je considère que quand quelqu'un ne m'a jamais parlé en vrai, et ne m'aime pas,
ça me fait ch*er.
Je me dis "mais il ne me connait pas"
"comment il peut ne pas m'aimer" donc du coup je me soucie de ce qu'il pense.
Alors que je devrais pas, je devrais m'en battre royalement les c******.
et ouvrir des huîtres.
Mais non.
"Vous avez tendance à tout remettre à plus tard jusqu'à ce qu'il ne reste plus assez de temps pour tout faire."
Bah comme 100% des humains *rires*
Faites pas genre, faites pas genre
Oh p***** ça va être les résultats mec
P*tain mais les questions elles sont GENIALES MON GARS
C'est le meilleur quiz du monde
T'sais on dirait le ... un truc de voyant où tu te reconnaissais dans tout ce que le texte disait sauf ce que tu sais pas c'est
que le texte il s’applique pour chaque humain
peu importe qui lit ce texte, il va croire qu'il a été fait spécialement pour lui parce que
c'est exactement ce que le mec ressent, ce qui est marqué dans le texte.
Bah là là en fait, c'est un peu le même délire que je ressens, je me dis << oh mon Dieu, ce quiz m'était destiné oooh >>
Ha les résultats ...Qui suis-je vraiment ? La réponse..
Avocat
...
C'est quoi avocat ?
L'avocat c'est ma bouffe préférée, mais à part ça..?
Nan même sans blague en plus c'est vrai
Je suis introverti
C'est marrant hein pour un youtubeur j'suis introverti, c'est ouf
Comme quoi que, c'est vraiment pas pareil le monde virtuel où tu parles aux gens à travers une caméra
que le VRAI monde où là les interactions sociales sont vraiment réelles quoi
J'suis INFJ
"Le type de personnalité INFJ est très rare et constitue moins de un pourcent de la population"
*surpris*
WHAT attends c'est glauque ça fait flipper, c'est que c'est un truc bizarre
"Les INFJ ont une tendance à considérer qu'aider les autres est le but de leur vie mais bien que l'on puisse trouver les gens qui ont ce type de personnalité en train de mettre
en marche des opérations de sauvetage et de faire du travail bénévole, leur vraie passion est d'aller au cœur du problème pour que les gens n'aient pas besoin d'être
sauvés du tout."
"Aller au cœur du problème pour que les gens n'aient pas besoin d'être sauvés du tout"
Bah c'est un peu ce que je fais à travers les vidéos dans le quotidien certaines personnes sont vraiment pas bien
et que ils ... enfin moi et tous les collègues YouTubeur et ça vous sort un peu de votre quotidien les vidéos.
Ça vous aide à avancer mais bon c'est, comment dire ...
C'est pas l'intention première de ce que je fais.
L'intention première c'est juste euh ...C'est juste du divertissement au même titre qu'un mec qui fait un film ou quoi.
Sauf que moi c'est de la m*rde au f.. f... MDR
"Les INFJ  partagent en effet une combinaison de traits fort unique : bien qu'ils s'expriment d'une voix calme et posée, ils ont des opinions très--
*Rires*
Calmez-vous
Dans les vidéos on y est pas "calme et posée", on est à la bonne voix irritante et adolescente horrible
"Ils sont fermes et ont un fort caractère, mais il est rare qu'ils utilisent cette énergie à des fins personnelles."
*respiration*
C'est vrai, c'est vrai quand c'est pour moi je vais pas trop me vénère ou quoi  je m'en bats un peu les c******
par contre si c'est quelqu’un d'autre ça me révolte
"L'égalitarisme et le karma sont des idées très séduisantes pour les INFJ et ils ont tendance à croi--.
*surpris*
Nan mais mec c'est ouf !
En fait ce qui me choque le plus dans la phrase c'est "l'égalitarisme et le karma" je ... je ...
Le karma mon gars, ma vie est basée sur le karma, c'est un truc de ouf
*lit les phrases surlignées*
C'est exactement moi mon gars, c'est ouf, mais je pense vraiment que ce que je suis en train de lire va ... dites-moi .. pour le coup dites-moi dans les commentaires
et là c'est pas pour, euh, avoir plein de commentaires et que ma vidéo soit référencée.
Est-ce que là le truc que je suis en train de lire c'est valable pour énormément de gens d'entre vous auquel cas c'est un peu une technique de voyant
T'as l'impression qu'ils connaissent ton caractère et que c'est personnel alors que ça marche à une beaucoup plus grande échelle ce qu'il raconte
Ou est-ce que vraiment les gens comme ça c'est rare, je sais pas. J'ai lu  que c’était un quiz très scientifique,  qu'il y a 16 types de personnalités possibles
mais que cette personnalité-là représente moins d'1% de la population, j'ai beaucoup de mal à y croire, pour moi au contraire c'est
j'ai l'impression que c'est vraiment une majorité, peut-être je me trompe complétement.
"Cependant , il est vraiment extrêmement important que les INFJ se souviennent de prendre soin d'eux-même. La passion de leur conviction est
tout à fait capable de leur faire dépasser leur point de rupture et, si leur zèle échappe à leur contrôle, ils peuvent se retrouver épuisés, en mauvaise santé et stressés."
*lit la phrase surlignée*
Eh bien avec YouTube on est bien dans la m*rde hein ?
Eh bah p*****
Allez le bip, on passe a l'outro *rires*
P***** ! J'suis sur le c** !
Les questions c'était long et tout
j'en pouvais plus
en plus il y avait des trucs hyper personnels et tout je me suis mis a poil, j'ai arraché mon pantalon comme les, les mecs qui font des strip-teases.
Je sais pas trop quoi penser. Est-ce que je me suis fait avoir par un truc de voyant t'sais, où genre c'est trop du bullshit mon gars
et en vrai 60% des gens on leur dit ça et il font << ah c'est trop moi c'est trop moi >>
Est-ce que je fais partie de ces gens-là actuellement ? Est-ce que je suis le cassos qui à pris le truc personnellement alors que ça marche pour plein de gens ?
Comme on l'a lu au début sur la page d'accueil du site, c'est vrai que c'est effrayant en fait tellement c'est précis.
Faites-le, dites-moi sur quoi vous êtes tombé,  j’avoue j'ai la flemme de le refaire mon gars c'est hyper long.
En plus c'est plus marrant si le test est vrai quoi, si vous répondez vraiment bah, ce qui correspond à vous en fait, vous voyez ce que je veux dire.
C'est bien si vous m'avez écouté j’espère que vous vous êtes pas trop fait chier. Dans tous les cas au pire vous en aurez appris plus sur moi pour ceux que ça intéresse hein.
Et pour la majorité qui s'en bat les c*uilles
J'VOUS B*ISE ... faites le test p***** !
C'est hyper intéressant, j'suis sûr ça va vous intéresser et que vous avez envie de savoir. De toute façon si ça se trouve vous avez déjà quitté la vidéo n'oubliez pas le pouce bleu avant de partir.
Steuplait vas-y !
Le mendiant... J'suis pas Nelson Mand-ela, j'suis Nelson Mend-iant.
Men---diant..
...
C'est de la merde. ALLEZ FIN DE LA VIDÉO
Au revoir merci PEACE